das ist die Stimme Deutschlands ist das ist
Nina pelo das ist klick zoom deine
Nachttalkshows also bitte abonnieren und
kommentieren und was läuft so
toll danke schön ja es ist nicht zu
viel arbeit und neues album die arbeit hat hier nicht
gecoacht  Als und bei der Stimme
Deutschlands ergänzt
sich das sehr gut und ich mag es wirklich
, das zu tun, was alles Musik ist, aber
das Coaching zu machen ist etwas ganz anderes
, als mein eigenes Ding zu machen, also
ist der Druck, wenn ich das Coaching mache, groß  Alles
auf das Talent und ich kann ihnen nur sagen
, mach das, aber weißt du, dann habe ich
auch Spaß daran, meine eigene Platte hier zu machen,
ok, was magst du mehr, ah,
Frage, ich meine, sie sind sehr unterschiedlich,
ich genieße es wirklich, zuzusehen  Talente
, mit denen wir in den
letzten Monaten gearbeitet haben, sind irgendwie aufgeblüht, wissen Sie,
und da sind wir bei unserem Final Four,
das von so vielen anderen
Sängern in der Show stammt, und das ist
wirklich aufregend, weil wir Leute
kommen sehen  lebendig und herauskommen  selbst,
aber dann liebe ich dich, ich habe Glück, dass ich
mein eigenes Ding machen kann und ich liebe es, meine eigenen
Songs zu singen, ja, und es hat bisher wirklich viel Spaß gemacht
, meine Musik einem deutschen
Publikum vorzustellen und Korea zu genießen, es ist ein viertes
Album, 4000, ja, aber  Ich glaube, es ist erst
die zweite von mir, die in
Deutschland veröffentlicht wurde. Ja okay, hier ist der
Wolf ein Titel und hebt die Hände
als Single
Es ist
wirklich sehr bekannt und es ist ähm, ich
hatte neulich meinen Song im Radio,
ja, das macht wirklich viel Spaß, es ist immer
schön, wenn es nicht zu Hause ist, und ich
bin solche Sachen aus Großbritannien gewohnt,
aber es ist immer toll, wenn du
waren im ausland und du hörst deine musik oder
du siehst deine mitarbeiter fühlen dann fühlst du dich
wie oh ich das ist ziemlich aufregend wenn
du deine musik hörst du wirst deine
musik manchmal als coach hören gut du meinst
wie was ist das ja was ist  es ich
ich ich singe korrigiert ist es perf  ect
genug, denn es ist seltsam, manchmal war mir
nicht klar, dass du weißt, dass es im Fernsehen
oder so läuft, und ich wette, ich dachte, ja
, das Lied, oh, ich bin es, es klingt ziemlich
seltsam,
aber du weißt, was du kannst, wenn du deine eigene
Musik machst  Seien Sie wirklich
technisch in Bezug auf sich selbst, aber Sie müssen
an einen Punkt kommen, an dem Sie die
Dinge loslassen und sie so sein lassen müssen, wie sie sind,
und ein Teil der Arbeit an der Stimme mit
den Talenten besteht nicht so sehr darin, die
ganze Zeit technisch zu sein  Ich denke, bei großartigem
Singen geht es oft um Emotionen, und
manchmal geht es darum,
die Kanten rau zu lassen. Sie kennen einige meiner
Lieblingssänger, sie singen nicht immer
schön im Einklang, aber sie haben einen echten
Charakter und eine Persönlichkeit, und ich denke
, das ist wirklich wichtig, okay, na und
Ist das ein wichtiger Punkt für Sie, wenn Sie
Ihren Sänger coachen? Ja, ich möchte das Gefühl haben, ich
möchte mich bewegt fühlen. Sie wissen, dass viele
Leute so singen können, wie Sie wissen, dass sie
Millionen von Noten spielen können
Ihr  Ah, weißt du, das sind nur
Techniker, ähm, aber was ich hören möchte,
ist echter Geist. Du brauchst Technik. Ich
mag keine Leute, die falsch singen
Über einen Menschen, der
mit einem anderen spricht, lässt du den anderen Menschen
etwas fühlen, das er im Alltag nicht fühlt,
also ist es dasselbe, was wir tun, wenn
wir Schwüre üben, sagen wir, dass sie mit einer Person sprechen.
Ja, ja, ich denke, damit Sie
wissen, dass es so ist  über Verbindung, ist das nicht
alles nicht nur Musikfilmmalerei, es dreht sich
alles um menschliche Gefühle und die
anderen Menschen verstehen und
sprechen mit ihnen, und das ist die Kraft
einer großen Stimme, wissen Sie, und ich denke
, das ist es, was die Menschen erkennen  Die
Show schreitet voran Die Leute, die
drin bleiben, sind die Leute, die sich
wirklich mit dem deutschen Publikum verbinden, und
Sie können dieses Wissen trainieren. Ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit größer
, dass
sie herauskommen?  Der schlechteste
Sänger kann einen Moment haben, in dem er
etwas Wahres und Ehrliches singen und
bewegen kann, und ich denke, es geht darum,
den Menschen zu helfen, das in
sich selbst zu entdecken, wissen Sie, und
manchmal vermissen die größten technischen Sänger
, dass sie zu sehr damit beschäftigt sind, zu singen
Menschen mit ihrer Stimme ansprechen,
also geht es darum, Menschen dabei zu helfen, auf
diese Weise aufzublühen, dreht sich alles um den
Charakter des Sängers, ja, seine
Persönlichkeit ist gut, ja, Persönlichkeit
Geschichte, was ist das
Besondere, das sie in ihrem
Leben durchgemacht haben, dass sie das Gefühl haben, dass
sie dir mitteilen müssen, dass viele Songs
viel damit zu tun haben, weißt du, denn wenn
du keinen großartigen Song hast, dann ist es das  Es ist schwer,
egal wie gut deine Stimme ist, zu
zeigen, was du wirklich fühlst, aber ja,
es ist eine knifflige Sache, die du lehren kannst, du
kannst so viel lehren, und dann dreht sich
alles um die Person, die nimmt, was du bist
sie zu zeigen und damit zu laufen und ist
es nicht so, dass die Stimme in dem
Fall ein Teil deiner Seele ist?
Schmerz, es geht um
Melancholie. Ich meine, das sind die Dinge
, die mich ansprechen
muss eine Persönlichkeit sein Ich denke, wenn
Sie denken wollen, ja, ja, ich weiß, ja,
aber ich denke, dass die Menschen
, die Sie wirklich bewegen können, manchmal Menschen sind,
die sehr still sind, und einige von ihnen tun nicht
viel, und sie sind still  Weißt du, ich
denke an Adele, wenn sie jemanden wie dich singt, den
sie nicht sehr oft macht,
ganz still steht und diese
schöne Stimme herauskommt und sie sehr bewegend ist und
es gibt keine Art, dass sie das
nicht tun muss, ja, also nicht
muss immer extravagante Persönlichkeit sein c
Ich bin wirklich klein und bewegend, aber trotzdem stark. Okay, ich denke, es gibt
viele sehr wichtige Tipps von euch.
Alle Leute, die sehen wollen, dass jeder
singen sollte, jeder sollte singen
Leben Ich
glaube, jeder hat ein Buch in sich
, ja, und ich glaube, jeder hat
sein Lied, das er wirklich
gut singt und das sich ausdrückt,
wenn er das Gefühl hat, nicht singen zu können. Ich
kenne niemanden, der Musik nicht mag und
Ich kenne niemanden, der leise, auch
wenn er nicht viel von seiner
Stimme hält, für sich selbst singt und es wirklich
genießt, okay, und ich glaube wirklich, dass jeder
Mensch das in sich hat, also geh unter
die Dusche und singe großartig, sing dein
Herz  aus ja okay danke sehr
gerne geschehen